Obviously, the market has responded and
>> there is no April Fools' jokes today. I don't have one.
>> Oh my god, I came in and I made the executive decision
to ambush you today. You are totally humiliating him in front
of everybody right now.
>> We got it here. PBD asking Adam about his recent debate
with Dave Smith. The most disastrous debate ever watched on the
stream, okay?
You're saying the United States is a terrorist organization.
You've already lost the debate. >> When our politicians
lie us into wars that slaughter millions of innocent people,
I consider that terrorism. I'll run circles around you on this,
dude. Check the scoreboard. Most unpopular war in American history
going in. Check the scoreboard. 13 dead Americans, millions of
innocent people being displaced. >> You have the luxury
of sitting in your little studio with your hooded sweater like
you're 17 years old. I have a wife and children. Who depends
on you, Adam? Your mom?
Okay. I also have a significant other. Adam Sosnick, legendary
meltdown, legendary failure, okay? We've never seen a debate
worse.
Let's check it out. >> Adam, you were on the Dave Smith
You and Dave Smith did a debate together on what do you call
it? On Piers Morgan. I think that's the first time you were ever
on. Mhm. Obviously, the market has responded
and
>> Right from the beginning. Mhm.
He He doesn't want to do this, okay? He does not want to address
this at all.
cuz you know you know why they're doing this is because every
one of their podcasts, all the comments are making fun of Adam
like the whole time for being like a relentless Zionist shill
who has no beliefs of his own. Okay? Everybody's making fun of
him, right? So, the market has spoken, Adam, and we have to address
this, okay? They They've been you know, saying their thoughts
on how it went, what you did, what was said. Dave has retweeted
and said something about this is the end of Adam funeral. He
made some comments that went HE PUT HIM IN A BODY BAG. BYRON,
[laughter] YOU RESPONDED. YOU MADE some videos at him as well,
but I just want to kind of get because a lot of times from the
audience, you have to know how this works. The audience sits
there and watches and says, "I know for a fact Pat prepped him
and the team prepped him and then this and this and that." And
they don't know what happens. I want you to share with us cuz
the audience is curious. They're asking me, "What is your impression
on how you did on the debate with Dave Smith?"
Okay. So, already getting to be some cope here. I do feel like
crackhead Barney was more put together than Adam was. And now
I'm starting to get why,
Now I'm starting to get why because PBD and the the Valuetainment
team prepped him, okay? He was from the >> Well, I Despite
what you think, I haven't listened or watched any of the internet
comments. Already voice
Well, I Despite what you think, I haven't listened or watched
you did on the debate with Dave Smith. Well, I
Despite what you think, I haven't
listened
or
watched any of the internet comments. Like I have Like I don't
go on to Twitter. I don't
check the comments. It's just not something that I do. Some people
are messaging me on the internet, "What do you think?" I don't
know what people are saying stuff and I'm listening to a song
called "Ain't Nothing Going to Break My Stride."
>> That's such a white woman thing. He had the worst moment
of his life and he's got a theme song now. "Ain't nothing going
to break my stride. Ain't nothing going to hold me down like
Dave did. I've got to stop getting I don't know. I can't do it.
I That's the best I can do, okay? My god, what the
There's no way he just said, "Oh, this is my song." It's like
a depression breakup song.
Bro, what? >> "Ain't nothing going to slow me down." And
that's how I feel about this. So, they told me last minute, "Hey,
you're going to go on Piers Morgan, sure." I think Tom was maybe
going to do it. Tom wasn't able to do it. They called me up.
I said, "Sure, I'll debate Dave Smith." Listen, there's no doubt
that Dave Smith is smart or wise or well-read. The same thing
could be said Bro, this is why this is why you shouldn't talk
about it. Already total cope. I mean, he's doing the quotes.
And trust me, that might actually be fair, okay? He might not
be smart or wise or whatever.
Like he's doing the quotes trying to say it's not this way, right?
But Adam has to admit he's the last person, the
last person who should comment on this. said about when you debated
a room full of 20 communists
on Jubilee. They were all very smart. I was very impressed by
all these people. But just because you're smart doesn't mean
you're wise. Now, do I think Dave smart is Dave Smith is smart
and capable? Sure. Do I think he's funny? No. Do I think he's
right? Definitely >> I'm asking you, how do you think you
did? I think I did fine. I I My intention wasn't to be play nice.
>> So, I went on Piers Morgan. I don't
Bro, you didn't do fine. You didn't do fine at all. Okay, we're
good. We're good. We're good. >> on going on Piers Morgan
every single day. That's not my thing. It's a food fight every
single day. Respect to Piers Morgan. I wanted to make some waves.
That was my methodology. I could be right. I could be wrong.
I don't care. >> Okay. So, you said you don't care? No,
meaning like I don't care what the market thinks of me. I know
what I believe. I know who I Dude, I guarantee you PBD's got
a whole thing about coping like this. He's going to have a whole
laundry list of things he's got to say to Adam now because of
how badly Adam's coping. Like you cannot say this. You can't
say you just don't care. It's your job to care. Your entire You're
a podcaster. How are you going to pretend that you don't care
what the market says about you? How are you going to How are
you going to pretend that you literally don't care about your
customers at all? What are you talking about, man? What the [__]
are you saying, man? I am I know what I stand for. I stand for
what America stands for. Dave Smith what me off. He continues
to say that America is the greatest terrorist regime in the world
and that the and that Israel is the greatest terrorist regime
in Oh, no, PBD. So what? That's his argument. >> Sure.
That's his argument. My point was that only 1% of Americans vote
for libertarians. He's a hardcore radical libertarian. So, when
you wrote the book Choose Your Enemies Wisely, you said, "Who's
your enemy?" Yeah. >> I said, "I don't know who my enemies
are. I don't really have a lot of enemies. You know me, Pat.
It's a big difference between the internet and comments and real
life. I walk around in real life. I have zero issues." You don't
have issues there. That's That's not the conversation I'm having.
PBD, it's very funny cuz this is like what Adam is doing is the
thing that all sales people will make fun of you for all the
time. Sales people are all about all about brutal honesty. Do
not get away from the core issue. You have a core problem right
now. You have to have a brutal brutally honest conversation about
it. And Adam is transparently like sprinting away from this conversation
as hard as he can. It's like, dude, you literally were incapable
of making any coherent
on anything here. You are totally like you are out of your depth
entirely and that's what everybody's making fun of you for. And
Adam's like, "You know me, I don't really have enemies." >> conversation
that that that I was just basically establishing is that Dave
Smith as as as potent as he might be on a podcast or even on
Joe Rogan's for that matter, people don't support this guy. I
support our troops. I support America. I support our allies.
>> I think I think Joe's had him on 20, 30
>> No, it's not irrelevant. So, ask whether you agree with
the guy or not, you know, Joe likes Dave, right? So, so the question
you got to ask yourself is from my perspective, there is issues,
there is approach, there is what's next for you. When I look
at everybody in a marketplace including myself, everybody in
a marketplace including myself, I I leave and I say, "Okay, how
am I recreating myself for this next phase? What areas do I have
where it's a leak for me? What habits do I have that I need to
pay attention to? When we started building an insurance company,
yesterday I had Lee Strobel on. We had a great conversation together.
One of the guys that I would study a lot was Billy Graham. And
Billy Graham and his friends in 1948, they came out with something
called the Modesto Manifesto.
I got no idea what he's talking about. I don't really care. The
The core thing is is Pat Pat is saying
Okay, PBD is is saying, "You got to look at yourself, man. You
got to look at yourself. It's You can't [__] up and
then go, 'Well, actually' You just do a bunch of coping. Especially
when all of your customers are saying that you are [__]
up. The product you're putting out is terrible. You cannot cope
about this, okay?" >> At that time, there was a lot of
pastors that were getting caught up with young girls. And they
came up with this thing saying, "Hey, what are our threats?"
And it came up with the threats that they had. It was four things.
One of the ones was pastors hooking up with members. Number two
was churches taking advantage of the members with money. Number
three was the ego of a pastor. When you get on stage and you
feel like, you know, you are God. Like some pastors actually
become God-like because of how much the church fears them and
they like that. Anyways, they go through this. I said, "Okay,
how do we want to build this company?" It's very hard You got
to You got to think about ways to improve. I'm asking
the argument is one end because I don't know if you focused on
making a I've seen you make better arguments with Bassem Youssef
than you did with Dave Smith. I didn't see you making arguments
on Dave Smith. And And And the reason why I'm doing this with
you openly and I'm talking to you openly with you is there's
an element of also representing
where you're coming from, where your expectation is, "Hey, when
you go and be professionals." That's not how I handle debates.
Dude, dude, dude. I I I'm going to back it up just a little bit.
That PBD said we're doing this openly, that's why we're doing
this openly. I can almost guarantee you that Adam did not want
to do this. Adam had no interest in doing this, and he is being
forced to do it. Cuz there's another thing for like sales guys,
if you actually believe any of these mantras, right? You got
to take your medicine when you [__] up. You got to.
You cannot get away from it. And
but at the same time, they all have egos. All of them have massive
egos. So, when they do [__] up, it's so hard to get
them to follow any of the They're so happy to do it to everybody
else. And they're so angry when people do it to them. But I know
that PBD would feel the need to do this with somebody, right?
He would He would feel the need to do it. And I feel like Adam
has to Adam had to know this is happening. You're saying Adam
seems blindsided. I don't think he's blindsided. He has to know
that this is going to happen. Everything I know about PBD tells
me this is going to happen, that he is not going to walk away
from this, right?
I bet PBD swaps segments. Maybe. But I'm telling you, this was
always going to happen like in a public way, so long as people
were slamming the comments, PBD is the kind of guy who believes
his commenters are human beings, okay?
Much to his Much to his uh much to Adam's chagrin, I guess.
Much to, you know, all wisdom to the contrary. Sorry, against
all wisdom to the contrary.
He believes they're human beings with with relevant and and coherent
opinions. I've seen you make better arguments with Bassem Youssef
than you did with Dave Smith. I didn't see you making arguments
on Dave Smith. And and and the reason why I'm doing this with
you openly and I'm talking to you openly with you is there's
an element of also representing
where you're coming from, where your expectation is, "Hey, when
you're going be professionals, that's not how I handle debates.
I don't handle debates that way. That's not my MO. So, if you're
close to me and you're handling it that way, that is not my style.
I I I don't I don't do I don't do stuff like that. And Dave and
I don't even agree on some of these issues. But if I'm having
a conversation, it's about what is this next phase. And by the
way, the reason why I'm having this direct feedback with you
publicly
is for the following reason. This is how I roll,
I will give you private
Pat did not discuss doing this with him beforehand. Never mind.
I I know Pat would do it, but Pat didn't say, "Hey, we're going
to do this on the the show
This does feel like a private convo. Yeah, it was never going
to be private with Pat. Never ever ever. >> have your back
100%.
I've always been like that. This is why my guys like working
with me, and they know how tough it is at times because I'm always
challenging them.
But if my private feedback that I'm giving doesn't land
and it feels like you have immunity to go run around and say
whatever you want to keep Oh, no.
Oh, no.
It's that he told him privately to take his medicine, to come
out and say like I lost, I didn't make ar- And Adam kept coping.
And so he's saying, "Now, I got to do it publicly. Now, I got
to stop you from coping publicly. No way. Oh, no.
That's That's insane.
>> This is going to be tough, man. And if I tough, I mean,
this is like Christmas come early for me, all right? This is
This is like I knew this is going to be good, but my day is now
made. Now that Pat said this Now that Pat said, "I know And but
when my private feedback's not actioned on, I got to do something
Oh. Thank you, Patrick Bet David, my hero.
But if my private feedback that I'm giving doesn't land
and it feels like you have immunity to go run around and say
whatever you want to keep saying, "I don't give a [__]
what people say." I do. There's an approach to take about this
game. I don't care that we have differences in debates. We We
push each other here, and we have arguments and, you know, comment
I side with Vinnie today. You know what? Today actually I side
with Adam. You know, there was a couple moments we had where
you had a couple clips that were like they sided with you. I
think Adam's the point today, and I'm like, "Okay, Adam had a
point." And then, "Hey, Tom. No, I'm siding with Tom today. Pat,
you were off today. No problem. But it's recreating for the next
phase of what is that next phase for you. And that's a very important
thing for you to be thinking about. I've had that conversation
with him recreating himself. I've had the conver- Wait. Adam
Adam, that's one very important thing for you to be thinking
about. But I got another important thing for you to be thinking
about. >> couple things I want you to be thinking about.
Number one, you
position with him recreating himself.
Legendary clip has to be put thrown in there. It has to be thrown
in there. >> conversation openly with me on what I need
to recreate. But for me, when I saw that, I'm like, you know,
you brought up another guy from the past that beat Dave. Great.
You know, you brought up a No, there there needs to be the the
the Adam that I've seen debate that is prepared.
He actually would have made some real good points there. And
you By the way, you've been a moderator for Zero Hedge with Dave
Smith and and uh what do you call it? The uh Laura Loomer, if
I'm not mistaken. Is that what you did? Didn't you moderate?
Yeah. And I was a pretty good job you did as a moderator. So,
I don't know. I'm saying this publicly to
this next phase requires all of us to recreate ourselves. And
that includes you in a big way. And I've said this privately
eight weeks ago, nine weeks ago at that dinner place we went
to, and I was very direct with you. But your your cornering me
to have to say this publicly to you right now. And you have to
make a decision on what you want to do with this next phase.
You got to recreate yourself. It's a very important thing that
I'm I'm being very respectful to you. And you had no idea that
I'm going to go here tomorrow. You had no clue I'm going to And
by the way, I'm being very respectful to you. And you had no
idea that I'm going to go here tomorrow.
What? I I feel like it's particularly humiliating to go, "And
I am being very respectful to you right now."
No, this is not respect It's like I Maybe there's some argument
you can have like I'm respecting you by actually you my opinion,
but you gave the the opinion already, and you are totally humiliating
him in front of everybody right now. >> no clue I'm going
to And by the way, I intentionally changed today's business
>> to to do this BECAUSE >> DUDE, NO WAY.
Oh my god, I came in and made the executive decision to ambush
you today. There's a I need to let you know this, Adam. I There
was a couple things that I needed to talk about in this podcast,
and number one was about what a you were in that debate with
Dave Smith, okay? We had to do this today because I respect you.
So, I had to point out that you in that debate, okay? challenger
to do it this way. But for me, sometimes you know, when people
say, "I don't care. I don't care. I don't care. I don't care.
I don't care." And And sometimes this is like the Trump effect.
Well, Trump doesn't care. Well, Trump doesn't give a [__]
Well, Trump doesn't do this. Well, contrary to popular belief,
Trump looks at every poll. Trump listens to every comment.
Trump is like a thin-skinned
Yeah, we all know that. Contrary to popular What What popular
belief doesn't include Trump is a thin-skinned who who follows
every piece of criticism about him? That's been known forever.
Trump listens to every criticism. So, what you think that Trump
does, I'm not telling you go read the comments the next day and
go through all chat. I don't recommend that at all. But I do
believe a little bit of criticism to see, well, maybe there's
a little bit of credibility there. There's a little bit of value
there for me to receive. How can I receive this and recreate
myself? Cuz if you're not too careful, Adam, and I'll open it
up to you guys if you want to say anything. I'll give you the
final thoughts, and then I want to get on to the next story,
but I wanted to open up with this get right into it. Um is the
following. There is no April Fools' jokes today. I don't have
one. Okay? So, if you got >> So, you get APRIL FOOLS' TOO?
>> AS I WAS EXPECTING AN APRIL FOOLS' JOKE, I don't have
one. This is not April Fools' joke. I know what day today is.
This is not a You know, I've had certain friends of mine that
are very good I used to be very good at the April Fools' stuff.
I don't have one today. Maybe I'll have one for you next year
when I'm in a diff- in a different mood. But this is the part
I want you to be thinking about is
the market
is going to criticize you.
There's a very big difference between the bots. I will I read
a comment yesterday made the most disrespectful comment to me.
And the first thing I did, I went to the account.
It got started in February of 2026. Huh. Weird. >> It has
two followers, follows 6,000 accounts. That's a bot of somebody
that created to say it. Forget about the bots. There are some
people that are giving real feedback that we have to pay close
attention to
you know, we can disagree. You know, even with the Dave Smith
part. Dave Smith's issues, we can sit down and have a debate
over the number, and I can still do it respectfully.
You know, even when I went to Jubilee, they dis- Dude, Pat's
giving something away about himself here, though, that he does
read all the comments. He reads all of them. And then when they're
negative, he clicks through the profile cuz he's like, "You're
a bot, aren't you? Ah, got you." >> respected me. I didn't
disrespect the kids Yeah. When I spoke to them. Our position
has to be a different position. And even when Trump calls out,
he still is very
paying attention to the likability score that he has. Love him
or hate him, people like him. I'll pause. Vinnie, any thoughts
you had? Of course. Absolutely. So,
Another legendary PBD quote. Love him or hate him, like him or
hate him, people love him. Or was it love him or hate him? Love
him or hate him, people like him.
Love Donald Trump or hate him, people like him. What? I'll just
break this down real quick. We didn't have this discussion prior.
Just kind of preemptively brought this up, and I'm totally okay
with it. If I wanted to have a
>> Dude, every moment every single moment of this stream
is gold.
I'm totally okay with it. You didn't sound okay with it when
you first brought it up. You coped a little bit right off the
bat. And now you look like you're about to cry.
I don't think you're okay with it. >> ideological debate
with Dave, I would probably rephrase it that the world is a dangerous
place, and he wants to pretend that he's an ostrich and not engage
with anybody. So, you know, to to use an analogy, if this guy
was a dating coach, he would say just sit at home all day and
wait for women to knock on your door, and that's when you can
respond to women. The world doesn't work that way.
Hey, Adam, that's still not an argument. It's getting close to
an argument.
Hey, we have to bomb those kids. That's your argument. Make it.
>> If you're a sales coach or if you're a sales manager,
that's like saying just just just stay stay by the phones what
What do you What do you think's the outcome of a debate?
The outcome of a debate >> Forget Dave Smith. Forget this
isn't a Dave Smith conversation. That could have been Joe John
Doe. I'm not talking to What is the purpose of a debate? We're
we're not aligned. What is the purpose of a debate? To find the
truth. The purpose The it's a clash of ideas. >> Sure.
So, somebody can watch and say, "Wow, good point. Never thought
about it that way. Let me go back and look at it, right?" That
is the purpose of a debate. The purpose of a debate is for me
to get it look at something when like the moment where Hillary
Clinton I will say I will say, as much as I don't really respect
Pat or anything he does, okay, cuz I know
There's There's people like this I can kind of respect and like.
There There have been sales people I've liked. But broadly, I
find them to be very scummy in a lot of ways. There's one particular
sales guy that I used to work with that I really like, and he's
I think he's a big Pat fan. He's a lot like Pat, okay? If you
meet these people, they're very charismatic. They're They're
like nice people to be around, okay?
with Pat, there's one thing you can expect a salesperson to do,
and that's
essentially identify the way they sell their thing to other people
and always prioritize that that like edge they have that lets
them sell, okay?
For Pat, he's selling like debates to people, and he says, "This
is what what people tell me this is the thing I think I give
as a product is people they come in, they watch, and they go,
'Oh, I never thought of it that way.'" Right? He is That's what
he's saying to Adam. And you are giving no element of what allows
us to sell this podcast did you give there? And you can't even
admit that to people.
So, I will say I agree with this. I think this is broadly what
people look at debates for, right? They want to watch that kind
of thing. They also want to watch somebody like smack down a
person that they hate, right? A person they disagree with. There's
There's two elements there, but it's
I think he's actually making good points. Is I had to say all
of that to say I think Pat's actually making a good point here.
That's the point of a debate to him. I'm sure Adam agrees, and
Adam made no effort towards like he made zero effort to give
the audience what they were what they were looking for, okay?
And that's what they're all commenting on as well. You didn't
give me the thing you promised. When you told me you were going
to debate, you gave me none of the things that you offer usually.
What the hell? and Trump are going at it, and Hillary says, "You
know, you know, him and all his he he didn't pay any taxes, and
he didn't do this, and he didn't do that." And then the moderator
asked Trump a question and says, "Is it true that you paid this?"
He says, "Yes. I will use every single tax code that you have,
just like all her donors do. And by the way, you've been there
for 36 years. How come you've never changed it?" So, me as the
voter sits there and
"That's a very good point." You've been there for 30 That's the
debate. It gets people thinking. So, if I'm going into a debate
and I didn't make anybody think, what was the purpose of the
debate? Sure. Well, now fair point. The point that I was trying
to make is that ideologically we're not aligned here. I'm supporting
Trump. Was I supporting Trump for 5 10 years? >> No, you
were not. So, I'm all behind Trump. Everybody wants to criticize
Trump right now. The thing that I'm
That There's no argument. That is not an argument. You just did
none of the things. He doesn't want to take his medicine. He
does not want to take his medicine at all. Adam, you have to
take your medicine or PBD he's not moving forward until you take
the medicine. So, the sooner you take it, the sooner we all get
to stop the humiliation ritual. So, please, for the love of God,
do not take the medicine, okay?
Keep coping. I will sit here for the rest of my life watching
you cope about this. It is delicious. Every moment of this is
delicious, okay? So, please keep coping cuz this is disastrous.
basically establishing is the fact that this guy has a luxury
of living in America and wants to criticize the heck out of Trump
when I'm defending Trump and our troops. The point that I was
saying is I'm defending Trump. Dave's the type of person that'll
root for the bad guy in the bad movie. So, that's what Dave is.
Aside from that, other than that, I understand what you're talking
about. The reason So, you look
My strategy, you don't understand, Pat. My strategy is literally
ad hominem. That is my strategy. My strategy is ad
The strategy I have is ad hominem. That's literally my strategy.
Okay, I get it. >> up the Coleman Hughes, and I encourage
people to go watch it.
This was the the sort of like the swan song event. Imagine you
hype up this event. Here's what's going The SLS is coming this
weekend. Here's what's going on, and this debate takes Dude,
look at the look in Pat's eyes. Hold on. This was the the sort
of like the swan song event. Imagine you you you
hype up this event.
is still not taking the medicine. I don't want to keep doing
this, but he's just not listening. He's just not listening at
Like Pat is actually annoyed that Adam is going on another tangent
and using to take the medicine.
You can see it in his eyes. He's like, "Dude, this dumb won't
take his
Accept this. Accept this criticism now. >> Here's what's
going The SLS is coming this weekend. Dude, literally disgusted.
Literally disgusted.
hype up this event. Here's what's going The SLS
is coming this weekend.
Dude, he's disgusted with Adam right
Oh, I love it. I love it. >> Here's what's going on, and
this debate takes place, and it was a 12-0 drubbing. So, that's
my point. Should I have conveyed it a little bit better? Sure.
Should I have not up brought No, you conveyed that point you
just made, Adam. You conveyed perfectly.
Everybody else is trying to tell you that that's not a good point
to make. You are a
for making that point, okay?
Everybody's been telling you that the whole time. You conveyed
the idea that you think Dave lost this debate very well. That
point was made 100 times.
And that's why we're all laughing at you. So, the idea that you
now come here and you go, "Listen, Pat, maybe I didn't make the
argument very well, but Dave lost that debate." We all get it.
He lost that debate legendarily. It was like the worst debate
he never lost. We all get what your argument is.
That That is not an argument against anything Dave's saying.
You're just attacking Dave Smith. You can go do that on Twitter.
That's not what a debate is for. >> brought up someone
else's debate in my debate, maybe I'll learn that for the next
time. That's fine. But the reality is this, he got whooped, and
I called him out on it. That's all it was. Yeah, but the the
it was it was your fight and his. Sure. For the next time, I'll
debate him just heads-on. I brought up something that
imagine you're fighting Manny Pacquiao, and instead of putting
your hands up and not getting your ass kicked, you just go, "You
lost to Floyd Mayweather, bro." "Hey, you lost to Floyd Mayweather,
bro." "You lost to Boom! You get hit in THE FACE. YOU LOST TO
FLOYD MAYWEATHER.
You're getting your your ass kicked. That's not how a fight works.
You're fighting that other guy. You got to box, man. Well, my
my feedback isn't actually
My feedback is
it's okay to pay attention to the pulse of the market every once
in a while. Good feedback's being given. Not 80% of people, not
90% of people, but there are reasonable people that will give
you good feedback. >> Sure. And none of us There's not
a single human being in the world that actually likes to be given
feedback that we get excited about it. So, it's not like anybody
likes it, but it's in those moments where your character is being
tested to say, "You know what? Let me receive some of this and
see if there's some good feedback and then process it." I I'm
I'm I'm going to turn this over to Vinnie. I'll say one thing.
You know what Vinnie and I do when you're not around? What's
that? >> We say, "Hey, what feedback do you have for me?
What feedback for me?" We actually talk. We actually convey.
How many times have we done stuff like that? The difference is
You know what the difference is? That Vinnie's not giving you
the Vinnie one is your friend. He's not necessarily going to
give you all the punches. Two, Vinnie is somebody who I guess
maybe likes you, agrees with you. I don't know what he's going
to say. I think it's Vinnie likes you. He's not going to He's
not going to be brutally honest with you, and there is some brutally
honest feedback out there, and it's hard to like somebody enough
to give them brutally honest feedback about something like this.
What's up? Here's the difference.
So, this this this event at SLS, I asked the question because
I used to always look at my guys and judge them on how hard they
work, how great they're on scripts, how many books they read,
and all this stuff. Eventually, I'm like, "Let me look at it
in a different way." It was
how much information does this guy retain from what I teach.
So, you teach something, this guy retains 10%, that guy retains
20%, this guy retains 30%.
Then, the next thing is, okay, so he's winning on retaining information.
He's smarter than you, let's just say, hypothetically, right?
Okay. Now, the next part is what? What's after
Implementation. Execution. He only implements of the 30% he retained
5%.
He retain he retain 20%, but he executes 20%. You retain 10%,
but you you implement 50%. Then it comes to coachability. Then
it becomes the speed of implementation. Then all of that stuff.
Feedback is feedback. It's receiving and implementing
that matters. That score of coachability, high low, is the difference
between you and Vinnie. And that's the coachability marker that
I want you to be internalizing for yourself. So, Vinnie, again,
I don't want to be on this too long. I want to move on. But you
want to say something? Adam, you're not coachable, dude.
Uh it's so funny the crossover with like the red pill space that
Adam would be very familiar with. Coachable is like what they
want their women to be and Pat's going, "You're not coachable
enough Adam. You're you need to be more coachable, okay? Vinny
very coachable. Vinny is very coachable. Anything I tell Vinny,
he's like, 'Yes, sir. Sir, yes, sir.' Adam
Not you, okay? Something said this will take me 2 minutes from
from a debate point of view cuz I'll give both sides. He's never
been in this in this environment meaning when they send a van,
when I go and do these debates with a panel of six, everybody's
yelling talking over each other. People don't realize you're
in a van, you're sitting in the sun in Florida. I'm red. I know
you were hot. Even what's his name was in there. Jaden was in
there. People like he's on I read the comments cuz I want to
know what what the temperature is. Dude.
>> Vinny, that's awesome, but what
I read the comments. They said, "I'm red and I'm on They know
the The commenters are pretty smart, okay? You can't hide very
much from the commenters. I was right I was on loads
God damn. Chris, the the the negatives were obviously you referred
to another debate which nobody wants to do. You were a little
off I felt cuz I know you as a brother. I know that you were
nervous. This is what bothered me Adam. We are in here and I
know what's going to happen today on this podcast. We're going
to go Israel's going to be brought up and we're going to go into
it. You are you are amazing at that debate and it I was disappointed
because you know, you're in the moment and you referred to whatever.
You have the arsenal. You had the ammunition. You had this big
ass arsenal and you just used a pistol. You were just like kind
of going after and doing personal. They run the the Vinny Manneck
dad.
He had expert advice instantly from Vinny. This this expert
on debate. >> disappointed cuz I was like, "Yo, you have
it. You have it. You didn't use it." And this is my attitude.
When I was young and I'd get my ass whooped, my mom would be
like, "You're going to go outside and you're going to fight that
guy right now. You're not going to sit here and let it fester.
I know that you're going to do it. You got to debate him again.
You have to do it again."
>> Wait, Vinny won? Oh my god. Vinny revolutionary Yes.
Yes, you have to debate again.
Vinny is making the content happen. You got your ass kicked,
you little [__] Get back out there and kick that
kid's ass just like my mom used to tell me. Very weird story,
but okay. Italian moms built diff, okay?
You you You think you're going to come in here? You can say my
house? You're you're getting your ass kicked like that? Nah.
Get out there and get your ass kicked again. Thank you, Vinny.
Okay. I time that you don't look like you have anything to say.
It's all good. We can just I don't I don't have anything to add.
It's all your fault. I was filling in for you, bro. It literally
Pat did say exactly the answer here Ashworth's boat. Yes. Pat
Pat gave the exact like thing that that gets said like you're
saying. I'm telling you sorry. He's he's like He's he's going
all around that exact thing. He's saying, "I need you to pick
up what I'm telling you for feedback more quickly. You are not
picking up that I'm telling you this went badly and you need
to stop coping about it. You're not picking it up fast enough.
I need you to pick it up." And Adam keeps coping and keeps coping
and keeps coping, right? And it's literally like, "Dude, I am
fine with you making a mistake, but I need you to admit that
it was a mistake. I need you to to understand how you could be
better. If you can't even admit that a mistake was made, how
are you ever going to fix it and be better? You literally can't.
You actually cannot.
So, you have to That's a step one. Identify the error. Right?
Be willing to accept the feedback
and then fix it. Find out how you need to fix it. Cuz I don't
want that happening again. That was embarrassing for all of us.
He doesn't include this, but that was embarrassing for the show.
You made us all look like because you're a guy who we have pure
conversations with and then you go and get your ass handed to
you that way. It's embarrassing for everybody on this broadcast.
See, that needs to not happen
And Adam goes, "No, you don't understand what my point was."
Everybody understands your point, man, okay? Stop getting your
ass kicked. No, no, no, no. That's No. Pat was very articulate
about it. He's got standards. We get feedback. We try to meet
those standards. We want to represent well wherever we are. Okay.
All right, I'll That guy just said exactly what I said. You embarrassed
us. You embarrassed us. And I'm okay with you making a mistake,
but you need to own that mistake and you need to be better. And
you are not owning the mistake and you're not committing to be
better because you're not even willing to admit that it was a
mistake. So, let's get you got to you got to pass step one or
there's going to be a problem here, okay? Also, there's going
to be a lot of quote unquote feedback in the comments of this
video, okay? It's going to be a whole lot of feedback in the
comments of this video.
Right? This is going to be brutal, I It's got to be it's got
to be like crazy brutal in those comments, no?
Cuz he didn't he didn't get it the whole time. He's never once
said, "You're right. I really [__] that up and I'm
going to be better next time."
Not even not even remotely close to an admission of fault. Talk
about the economy and I'm very excited about talk about him talking
about it with him because he's got very good angles he goes through,
but to those of you guys that message, thousands of you that
message saying, "We miss you. We want to hear the conversations.
We want to hear the exchange." and the podcast keeps climbing.
Every time we're doing a podcast, it climbs and it happens because
of you guys. And I'm grateful for you and for the 51% of you
guys that tune in on a weekly basis, we would like to take that
down to 25%.
51 of you 51% of you that watches this who doesn't subscribe,
it would mean the world to us if you do so. We're real close
to getting past 3 million. We'd like to take this thing to 5
million subs and Oh, interesting. Different different podcast.
Is this Valuetainment It's not Valuetainment money. It's different
podcast though. Interesting. I we got to go to we got to go down
to the comments,
Here it said, "Adam, what's your point?"
I've been waiting on this autopsy. PBD is basically telling Adam,
"You better not embarrass me or my brand ever again after Dave
destroyed you." Yep. That is that is you're embarrassing us and
show me that you're capable of not making the same mistake again.
It's It's him explicitly saying, "I don't care that you made
a mistake. There's no we don't have to go back and like really
ex extol we don't have to like go over in excruciating detail
how you [__] up or something. Just admit you made
a mistake and that you will be better. It's not a problem that
you made a mistake, but you got to be able to not make that mistake
again. And everything you're saying right now is leading me to
believe you're going to make the same mistake again." And Adam
was like, "Well, actually
I think you're not getting it, Pat. Here's the same mistake again."
And Pat's like, "No, I am getting it, Adam. I need you to stop
doing that." And Adam was like, "I got you, Pat." Same mistake
again.
NO, ADAM, STOP STOP, ADAM. YOU GOT TO
PLEASE. It's a weird way to tell someone that they're getting
fired soon. It's literally not that they're getting fired soon.
This is like
Dude, I'm I'm going to give you the comparable that I think there
is, okay? Cuz I I genuinely think that they're not lying when
they say, "You're smart enough to debate with us. You should
be able to debate with Dave Smith."
What they're saying is, okay? This guy is showing up to work
without deodorant on every single day. And people like, "Hey,
it's not even a problem that you did that. I don't care. We're
not going to call you stinky anything, but you got to put deodorant
on tomorrow." And Adam goes, "I smell great. I don't know. Maybe
maybe I'm just not explaining to you right, but I smell great."
I smell fantastic.
And they're like, "No, Adam. Trust me, every single person can
smell what you smell like. You smell like
You need to stop or start putting on deodorant, okay? When you
come to work."
It's like not a thing that they don't they think he's incapable
of fixing. They don't think he's They don't think he's like incapable
of pulling his weight in the company. They're just like this
is a totally fixable mistake that you are somehow getting tripped
up on and we don't understand how you're getting tripped up on
it. So, you got to stop, please.
Adam as far as we can tell is just like, "I smell fantastic,
man. I smell
Yeah, I try I'm trying to give something that is like it's not
even a big deal right now. It's like kind of a big deal. It actually
makes the workplace worse for everybody, but it's it's like not
even a big deal anymore. It happened. I can get past it cuz you
are a valued member of the company.
But man, you got to make sure it doesn't happen again, okay?
It can't keep happening. Rip Adam. It wasn't a debate. It was
a funeral for Adam. The fact he lacks the humility to admit it
makes Adam a major albatross for PBD. That's That's what it is,
man. Adam needs to take his medicine, okay? Take your goddamn
Well, hold on. I didn't say
I didn't say he's not getting fired. I said the goal of this
conversation wasn't to let Adam know that he's going to be fired
soon. It's not the goal of the conversation, but based on how
this conversation went, I would say, "Yeah, I wouldn't bet on
Adam being there long term."
Cuz he just absolutely refused to take his medicine and Pat was
frankly bewildered. Like he actually looked disgusted. And I
don't think I was just catching him at a bad moment there and
zoomed in at a bad moment. I think he was genuinely disgusted
that he laid out the the problem to Adam and Adam literally couldn't
hear it because of his ego. Right? This isn't a last chance conversation.
That's not what this is. I don't think so. Unless So, he said
the thing about we talked about it in private. I don't know if
that's what's going on here or not. I don't think it's a last
chance combo. I think probably if you went and got destroyed
in the debate again and made no arguments again, that would be
pretty bad, okay?
All you got to do is admit you [__] up, man. Just
do a little little tiny little admission of a mistake. But he
can't.
And that's that again like the like the commenter said, that's
the albatross. That's like Adam, you are signaling to me if you
put it in in PBD's like view of it how he described it like himself,
okay? Adam, you're saying to me right now
that you don't see the a problem here that you can't fix it.
Right? That you have too big an ego to make sure you don't embarrass
all of us. And that that only goes one way long term, right?
You are going to embarrass us again and again and again.
Oh [__]
Adam Sosnick's takedown of Dave Smith backfired. There [laughter]
is a weird
I just noticed a Warren Smith video.
>> Warren Smith getting in on the Adam Sosnick hate? You
love to see it. You love to see it. I might check this out, okay.
Listen to Dave's funeral.
Oh, hold on. Where's the Albatross comment? Adam embarrassed
himself. Tom didn't have anything to add. His mind was His mind
was saying, "Hopefully this guy will mature or or move on." Adam
is like a boat anchor that's in the water while the boat is trying
to move. He's holding you back. But if PBD gets rid of Adam,
please do not bring Cuomo to fill the void. Father-son talk.
This is harder to watch than the debate they're talking about.
Ah, that's debatable. That's That's debatable. This is harder
to watch than the debate they're talking
No, they're both pretty hard to watch.
I think they're both pretty hard to watch, man. Clicked on the
video, came straight to the comments. It's the long-winded stories
before he answers a question that gets me. Pat is embarrassed
of Adam. Adam is so smug about all of this. PBD pours his heart
into the guy out to the guy, and he just makes excuses about
it. Read the room and take some accountability, Adam. That's
kind of rough, man. It's funny.
I can tell, you know how these these commenters, they're unironically
like a sales team for PBD.
They're unironically like coached on his way of thinking, you
can tell, cuz I can intuit the way PBD thinks, cuz I've met a
bunch of sales people just like him, and I've had to work with
them and and like get them on my side of an argument before.
So, I know people just like that, I can do it pretty easily.
But these guys, they don't know PBD very
but all of them can just like intuit the way he's thinking about
this, right? It's about accountability. Show me that you don't
have an ego, that you can take accountability, fix your mistakes,
and we can all move forward. Uh maybe it's obvious to everybody,
but it's just funny. When you have someone like Adam in your
inner circle in your organization, it makes you look bad. Can't
stand Adam. He really brings down this podcast.
By the way, I don't think Adam necessarily brings down that podcast.
Like I'll be real, Vinnie's never struck me as some great philosopher,
either,
I don't think he brings down the
But this is like a major a major red flag, a massive red flag
that's very difficult to resolve, okay?
It's He's putting himself above everybody else. It's what it
is.
That's how it looks to the audience. That's how it looks to Pat.
That's how it looks to Vinnie. That's how it looks to Tom.
He's just putting his own ego above everybody else. He's going
to risk their whole thing. He's Right? It's just indicative of
this. You're going to You're going to totally put your ego above
anything we're doing here as an operation.
Sad. Very sad, okay? Has Vinnie ever been dressed down after
an appearance on Piers? No, but Vinnie Vinnie
One, I don't think Vinnie's like very invested in people thinking
he's like super intelligent, okay? Uh thank you, Diggers, for
the raid.
But two, Pat has already said that Vinnie does this thing. I'm
guessing Vinnie has gotten feedback and just like took it and
implemented it. The That's the whole conversation, right? Hey
Adam, when I tell you what you [__] up, you do not
listen.
Hey Vinnie, when I tell you that you [__] up, you
do listen. I love how you listen when I tell you that you [__]
something up, Vinnie, and then you fix it. That's awesome. I
love that. Vinnie is still thinking about his Sargon debate.
He mentioned the red comment. These guys say I turned red, yeah.
Well, no, he said that was in the comments of a video, so a little
different, but I'm sorry. I do I I can just watch again. I want
to see I want to see if Warren Smith gets it. Is Warren Smith
going to get it?
I feel like this is the worst video for Warren Smith to pick
with regards to the Adam Sosnick stuff,
to be honest, Dave Smith does Warren Smith's job for him. Dave
Smith explains exactly what's getting [__] up, exactly
how Adam is [__] up. Like you are literally not making
the argument at all. Oh god. We totally agree with Vincent O'Shana
that Adam Sosnick and Dave Smith should have totally should have
another debate. @saztalksmoney and comicdavesmith, when can we
book you in? Oh, no.
Dude. Vinnie. Vinnie.
Vinnie set him up. Vinnie Vinnie, the content god.
I do agree, yes.
Dude, that's so funny. Man, there's I'm telling you, there's
a content creator behind Piers Morgan that could be like a content
creator on their own. All of Piers is I know Piers doesn't have
any of these instincts about online content himself. I know he
doesn't. There's somebody pulling the strings behind Piers that
whatever Piers is paying them, he needs to double it. Cuz there's
somebody there who knows the online sphere and is saying, "Go
get this done. Go Here's this clip. You got to go tweet this
clip right now and say you need them back on the show." Right?
And I don't think Piers has those instincts. I think somebody
else is making that tweet, or he hired somebody who's like got
a good got a good eye for it. It's not like it's crazy to connect
the dots there, but Piers is always on top of this stuff. There's
somebody There's somebody in that org who's just very content-oriented
every single time. It's Mr. Suds. I don't think it's Mr. Suds,
I don't think it's Mr. Suds. That's [__] up.
Stop talking about Mr. Suds. What the hell What the hell? To
right now. You're not going to sit here and let it fester. I
know that Dude. Vinnie Vinnie reliving some childhood trauma,
W?
Dude. He's like literally his eyes swollen shut, he's bleeding
out of his nose and his mouth, and his mom's like, "You got to
go fight him again." Yeah, I know you got your ass kicked, but
you got to go fight him again.
No, I know you're not going to win. I just want you to get your
I just hate you, Vinnie. I just hate you. You're a shitty You're
a [__] son. I just want you to go get your ass kicked
again.
What the heck? That explains the brain damage. Well,
Okay. I don't know why Warren Smith's doing this. I feel like
Adam No, I feel like Dave Smith did his job for him, so we'll
see what Warren adds here.
is so [__] embarrassing, man. I had to use logic
and a measured approach to whether or not I supported Trump.
Okay. Uh what does that have to do with
Me and Warren on the same page. Let's
>> Said what? That I'm a radical libertarian? Yes, absolutely.
Yes. Okay, perfect. So, when you're something you're radical
what
What what I believe is true Americanism.
This is why you call Sure. This is why you call the US military
the greatest terrorist organization on Earth, right? Because
you're a true American? Because you're a true patriot? Is that
why, Dave? Because something tells me you have what is known
as clickbait of the mouth, and you're using this these instances,
these wars, to garner attention for you.
You know, for Adam I think to say it's clickbait or that I just
want to get out in front of the camera, I think we're all equally
in front of a camera right now, and it's kind of weird to accuse
someone else. I very much believe the things I'm saying. Now,
to Adam's point,
Look, I'm trying to get to it, but there's a lot here.
Good, you're taking Let's go. Wrap it up. Throughout this conversation,
Adam is artificially trying to establish a frame that is not
real. Dave is not on the back foot in this conversation at all.
I'm saying when people come on and say Iran is the biggest state
sponsor of terrorism, well, just like give me an objective definition
of what terrorism means, and then let's apply that standard universally.
Dude, I I swear um Hutch doesn't do this the same way Adam does,
but it's very Hutch-coded, right? That like everybody else can
see what's happening in the
Hut Trump is the person who actually does this and tricks people.
Adam is incapable. Um Hutch does the same thing as well, where
everybody sees it one way, right? And they're like going to keep
saying that it's not that way. It's like, "Dude, you can't fight
I I would say Hutch establishes false framings as much, but I
It's one of those things where everyone else can see it and you
can't, and it's really unfortunate for you, cuz you can't see
that we're all seeing the same thing. You You're like unaware
of what the majority of people are seeing right now. Very funny.
Uh but Trump does this all the time. Trump used to frame Trump
is like the master of framing the conversation, framing like
what the what is actually happening in the situation and he does
it constantly. Very salesman-like
tactic. And if you're going to sit here and say, "Look, America
has given billions, tens of billions of dollars to the IDF in
the last few years." We've also, by the way, given a lot of weapons
and money. Your Your first guest on this show there, the head
of the Obama deep state, was using Al-Qaeda bin Ladenite head
choppers on the ground in Libya and in Syria. And yes, Adam,
I would also consider it when our politicians lie us into wars
that slaughter millions of innocent people and in many cases
target those innocent people, I consider that terrorism as well.
There's the answer, Adam. And if you want to keep doing this,
buddy, you can tell me to check the scoreboard. I'll run circles
around you on this, dude. He has a valid point. It's going to
come down to the intentionality around taking out civilians.
What has America done that would compare to what happened on
9/11? Compared to people hijacking airplanes to crash into buildings
filled with civilians. Does Adam land a single blow? He has the
potential to land the blow around the claim of America being
the worst terrorist organization, but even there he fails. You
live in America, tough guy. You have the luxury of sitting in
your little studio with your like you're 17 years old. The regime
Do you mean all American presidents? Who's your favorite president
in the last 50 years? Adam, I'm 17 years old. I have a I have
a wife and children. Who depends on you, Adam? Who Okay, I also
have a wife and children. So, you want to go personal? Oh, man.
All right. To be fair, [clears throat] Yeah, you have to include
it. You have to include it, but it's not really Warren's content
most of the time. >> made it about the person rather than
the logic. First, Dave comes in, cleans it >> You have
a significant >> Hey, we can go as personal as WE CAN GO
NO, I'm trying not to Speaking of personal, do you want I want
to respond to one thing. I don't care, Adam. I don't care, Adam.
I know CUZ YOU DON'T KNOW ANYTHING. You're a radical. So, stop
picking a fight with me, dude. You don't know anything about
anything. You're Pat's guy. >> I like you. I like you.
Here's what I was saying. I WAS OH, I forgot he did that. I Dude,
that's
That's another reason PBD would have been annoyed, right?
PBD's name getting used next to like total incompetence like
this. He would have been annoyed about that, for sure.
Right? That's why the conversation comes up. You're Pat's guy?
And Pat's like, "Yeah, that is my guy."
That is my guy. I do need to fix
I can see it. Pat immediately taking accountability for the thing
he [__] up in his own head. That is my guy. Maybe
I need to re-evaluate. How do I fix this? What do I need to fix?
What do I need to re-evaluate right now? >> Damn. Okay.
Zay Zay, here we go. I'll talk now for a second. I'm defending
the military right now. You're basically saying that all our
boys and that go to the military are all terrorists. That's what
you're saying. You're equating that the United States of America,
the IDF are the equivalent of ISIS and Al-Qaeda. By the way,
I also used to respect you until until you went on a little podcast
called Coleman Hughes. And this is where this falls apart. He
starts bringing up Coleman Hughes's conversation with Dave Smith
saying, "You lost to Coleman Hughes. Therefore, you've already
lost to me. That doesn't logically track." What happened on that
podcast, Dave? This is the problem.
>> PBD's a Trump [__] too, though. Yeah, but
we're we're separating shades of [__] here that like
in such a way that PBD is a lot smarter than Adam, it seems like.
Or I should say
PBD's probably not even really all that smarter than Adam. Or
all not all that much smarter than Adam. PBD is just capable
of like
through effort building on himself. PBD like make sure he doesn't
make the same mistake twice. He just builds himself up over time,
right? That's That's all I would say is PBD's probably just a
guy who's made a lot of mistakes in his life and tries not to
repeat them. Yeah, I It's like not even intelligent.
>> I'll do it I'LL DO IT RIGHT NOW, DAVE. Why can't you
make any of the arguments that were made by Coleman Hughes? Why
can't you point to any of Coleman's arguments? I'll do it right
now. Cuz here's what Dave is. Here's Dave Here's Dave Smith.
By the way, 1% of Americans vote for libertarians every year.
Now, this is just an appeal to popularity. More people disagree
with you than agree with you, therefore you're wrong. It has
nothing to do with the logic he's laying out. It's a logical
fallacy. So, you're trying to basically say that you know more
than the average American. 1% of Americans vote for your people,
Dave. Why don't you run for something? Why don't you stand for
something? You stand for nothing. Okay, can I respond to this
again? Pierce, this is the level of substance No, no. Pierce
is just sitting there watching this like, "What is happening?"
Here we go. I'm going to tell you a story, [clears throat] Dave,
and then you can respond. Cuz this is where I lost respect for
you as a debater. Cuz I was like, "Oh, this guy, Dave, he actually
knows some stuff. He's doing his thing." And then you showed
up on Coleman Hughes's podcast. Uh Pierce, do you know who Coleman
Hughes is? I do. He's been on the show. I've been on the show
with him. Perfect.
Perfect. That's this guy right here, just in case. What are you
doing? Why are you showing a video of Coleman Hughes? It's It's
the camera that doesn't see. But what is the point you're making?
I I watched his podcast. The point is this. Dave Dave gets out
there and he tries to bully people and say that he's so smart.
He reads a lot a lot of books. Good for you, Dave. But what happens
when you read it to somebody run into somebody who's way smarter
and bullies the bully? I remember growing up in the town of Miami.
So, there was this kid who used to pick on all the kids that
that we went to school with. He's been spending too much time
with Patrick Bet David where he goes off on these tangents. Okay,
let me tell you the story. So, there's a bully and then suddenly
there's a new kid and he beats up the bully. Wait, Warren actually
won? Wait, Warren's actually awesome Warren totally total Warren
victory? You love to see it. Oh my god.
He actually He picked it up perfectly. It might work for PBD.
It doesn't I I'll be honest, Gringo. I can't see I can't see
DKF I can't see his messages. He's there, but I I can't see them
on my chat, unfortunately or fortunately, I'm not totally sure.
>> And one
Oh, what did What did you ask? Hey, if I paid and got unbanned,
I would get the role where I can't be timed out or banned, right?
Um not in the chat, but in the disc And also, no, you can't just
break the rules entirely. You get favorable treatment,
you got to be willing to pay 100 bucks,
If you If you paid for the the 100 bucks, I'll think about it.
>> Okay, some new kid showed up and he goes, "Oh, yeah,
yeah. Let's go, buddy. Let's do this." And the bully goes, "Oh,
what do you mean? What do you want to do?" And he goes, "No,
yeah, you want to fight everybody? You want to take everybody's
lunch? Let's go." And the new kid beat the crap out of the bully.
And here's what happened with Dave. He's out there just doing
his little podcast thing, debating like you said, Ben Shapiro,
19-year-olds. And then all of a sudden this whole conversation
about Wesley Clark and I saw him on your podcast about a week
ago, Pierce. And this memo, here you go, Dave. Remember this
memo from Wesley Clark? Why do we need to see that? This is so
cringey. That you use the site everything. This is adorable.
That you use the site Yeah. That is adorable because your whole
foundation is based on some memo. Well, I'm I'm not quite sure
what No, Adam, I'm not quite sure what is the point you're making.
>> Even Pierce is just like, "What are you doing?" The
point is this. Dave has You gain DKF's 100 and lose Jake's 100.
Jake canceled his sub a while ago.
Jake has not No, Jake has not been giving 100 for a long time,
Top Bronson.
Jake Jake don't get the protection of the the $100 donation per
month anymore,
So, I I literally just told Jake, "You pushed me to this. I'm
going to have to accept this money." I'm going to have to accept
it. I'm sorry, man. >> zero credibility at this point.
Dave has zero credibility at this You don't really get to decide
that. You don't get to decide that. The audience gets to decide
that.
What audience? The four people that show up to your comedy show
at the ha ha ha? I don't know if this is the right move. I don't
know what the classified information is. I don't see how this
ends. It's a strange time. I think many people feel something
similar. Wow, many people feel something similar. Amazing